what would you want to say to Nick if
you could just look in that camera right
there and say something what would you
what would you say I will always love
you and and I will always have
forgiveness in my heart for you Nick
Carter shares a heartfelt tribute to his
younger brother Aaron on Sunday
following news of his death
alongside a slideshow of photos of the
two together throughout the years Nick
pinned a touching message quote my heart
is broken even though my brother and I
have had a complicated relationship my
love for him has never ever faded I have
always held on to the hope that he would
somehow someday want to walk a healthy
path and eventually find the help that
he so desperately needed I'm used to
people coming up to me oh hi Nick's
little brother how you doing so you know
it's kind of like I said you know I get
used to it but Nick did get me started
in this and I thank him for that very
much Nick add it quote sometimes we want
to blame someone or something for a loss
but the truth is that addiction and
mental illness is the real villain here
I will miss my brother more than anyone
will ever know I love you chis now you
can finally have the peace you could
never find here on Earth I love you baby
brother I'm proud of him he's always
been the brother that's been like a
father figure
ET can confirm that Aaron will found
dead on Saturday at his home just
outside of Los Angeles Aaron was 34 and
his cause of death has not been revealed
at this time
are you still sober what kind of Journey
are you on now or what I smoke weed I
mean there I have anxiety problems I
take medication for anxiety like I mean
it's just it's just what it is you know
the last several years proved to be a
trying time for both Aaron and his
family with the singer going public
about his mental health struggles in
September of 2019. Nick and Aaron's twin
sister Angel even obtained a restraining
order against him which led to a rift
between the siblings Aaron announced at
the time that he was officially done
with Nick tweeting quote take care Nick
Carter we're done for Life EC was last
with Aaron and his mother Jane in 2019.
you know what the hopes of the future
are this don't come at me the wrong way
because I I will I will fight to protect
my rights and with our four brothers
stood for but air uh that being said
Aaron loves his family very much and
that's where his heart is at and that's
where he's coming from he's coming from
love and he's just wanting to see it
return